a real chance to win the AFC
North. I mean it chances to win
some of those games they drop
back to back games at home. But
now they figure out a way to go.
Get a win,
the Ravens have a loss because
they're without Lamar Jackson.
So they take an ell. The
Steelers come back and figure
out a way to get a win. Who do
you think winds up? Taking
the north of Daniels have that
three in one record in
the division,
which may wind up push them over
the top. And this thing it
would have thought.
You know, I look at the
Pittsburgh Steelers and you
know, Mike Tomlin has these Guys
fighting and clawing
the Baltimore Ravens. We talked
about it. They're very
resilient team. But at the end
of the day, the most complete
team is the Cincinnati Bengals.
I believe they're the most
complete team
there Joe burrow, and those
weapons that he's got those
defense that young Defenders
flying around. It just seems
like they have a comfort level
with one another and they're
starting to trust each other
and are very good team.
It's gonna wind up being a
really interesting
decision for this entire Brown,
the probably starting with
stefanski even above still fancy
and whether or
Not they want to go all-in on
Baker, Mayfield. Now, as
the franchise quarterback Rodney
because this year, he's been
hurt. He's battled through all
kinds of injuries. This one of
the most pivotal games of the
season and he has to miss it
because of covid, even
as he's starting to get healthy.
Where would you even begin to
try to make the decision?
Whether or not Baker? Mayfield
is a franchise quarterback and
one that's worth paying it may
wind up being close to 30 some
million dollars per year.
Brother, they had all these
years to figure it out, you
know, be like, yeah, you've got
it right in front of you. Now,
you have to decide
and even if you don't want to
decide on a long-term contract
for this guy, maybe what you can
workout is a fair one year
deal. A really fair. One-year
deal
is that number 20 million? Is
it? 25 million is a 22 million
but maybe a one-year deal, maybe
another prove it year so
he can go out there,
you know, get some more weapons,
retool the offense and
see what Really working with
what a healthy Baker. May feel
your thoughts.
Yeah,
I would do it. I would do it. I
mean, I think people very
quickly forget that how bad
Cleveland was. What was it 20
some quarterbacks that have gone
through there and it has
he been playing like Baker
Mayfield has been playing like
Patrick Mahomes this year has
been playing like one of the
true Elites and of the young
quarterbacks that are in
the league. No, he hasn't but
he's also been dealing with at
least
three significant injuries. I
mean lower body injuries that
are affecting his as Mobility
affecting the bootlegs.
Everything that's the fancy
wants to do
with that offense. But what's
been impressive to me is that
he continues to play, right?
Like Baker wants to be in
the game. You want to be with
his teammates he's tough and and
I've been around the AFC North
for a long time. Ben.
Roethlisberger has been that guy
for Pittsburgh. That is
battling through things.
But he's always playing and
always giving you a chance to
win.
Given what that defense is given
that you have Jarvis,
Landry leading that offense and
he seems to have a great
relationship with Baker
Mayfield. There's no way I'm
breaking this. Thing up and
risking going all the way back
down the road of 0, and 16, and
losing season after losing
season.
I'm keeping stability, and I'm
keeping Baker, Mayfield hoping
he gets healthy for next year,
and maybe what you can do is,
maybe you approach, Baker,
Mayfield and say, look Baker. We
want you here long term, but
we can't pay you up or to 34 35
million dollars a year. If you
want to
take a teen friendly deal. Maybe
we guarantee you a little
bit more, but annually, we're
not going to pay you. Maybe we
pay you 25 million a year as
Opposed to 30 million a year.
He's making money off the field
and plus that gives them
leverage
where they can go out and it can
go sign some better
players. They can go out and
pursue more free agents and
sign some of their own upcoming
free agents.